it was a blaze scene for miles in the
night sky an apartment complex under
construction
now all that's left ash and rubble and
now the search for who
started it thanks for joining us at noon
i'm christian casadis
the eli at fort apache complex near
tropicana burned down last week
that's where bianca holman joins us live
with the information bianca i understand
authorities announced a short time ago
that arson is to blame right
investigators believe that the fire here
at this apartment complex under
construction
was not an accident investigators are
looking through surveillance footage
they are interviewing witnesses
and they are also analyzing evidence
from the debris
now this all started late night on
monday january
18th intense winds made it extremely
difficult to control this fire
the blaze caused almost 30 million
dollars in damages
because of the large fire scene clark
county requested the aid of the atf
national response team the 25 person
team concluded
the cause of this fire was intentional
arson is a dangerous act of violence
posing a significant threat to the
community
the fire caused extensive damage and
could have tragically resulted in
serious injury or loss of life
atf remains committed with our partners
to finding
and bringing the perpetrator of this
crime to justice
clark county fire department and the
local atf office will continue the
investigation
now there is a 10 thousand dollar reward
if you know anyone in connection to this
fire
reporting from tropicana in fort apache
bianca holman 8 news now